It is now my distinct pleasure to
introduce our keynote speaker:
business leader,
investment icon,
philanthropist,
business school alum,
university trustee
and Carnegie Mellon champion
David Alan Tepper.
Oh, I have several pages to read,
David.
Through his legendary business
savvy
and investment expertise,
David has earned an unrivaled
reputation as one of the most
successful hedge fund
managers in the world.
But he's equally well known
for his passion
for philanthropy.
His belief in the power of higher
education,
and,
of course,
his exceptional service
and generosity to his
alma mater Carnegie Mellon
University.
David grew up not too far from
here in the Stanton Heights
neighborhood of Pittsburgh.
The middle of three children,
I should just add that
his mother,
Roberta, is here
with us. Would you please
acknowledge
Roberta?
He went to the University of
Pittsburgh
for his undergraduate degree in
economics
before receiving his MBA in 1982
from our Graduate School of
Industrial
Administration.
It wasn't called the Tepper School
back there,
I know.
In 1985,
he was recruited by Goldman Sachs
as a credit analyst,
and, within just six months,
he became the head trader on
their newly established high-yield
bond group.
This was the first clue
that David was a force
to be reckoned with on Wall Street.
In 1993 — the
same year the web
entered the public domain — David
established Appaloosa Management
and, over the last 25 years,
has built an impressively consistent
record of high returns.
Appaloosa currently has
approximately
$17 billion under management
and has yielded gross returns close
to 40 percent per year
over the past 20 years.
Through the David
Tepper Charitable Foundation,
his philanthropy has expanded
opportunities
for education,
helped to fight hunger
and homelessness,
and provided much-needed disaster
relief.
He has generously donated a total
of $125 million
to Carnegie Mellon University,
including naming
and endowing the Tepper School of
Business,
where he serves on the school's
Business Board of Advisors.
And in 2013,
his most recent transformative
gift enabled
the creation of a state-of-the-art
facility
on the new David A.
Tepper Quadrangle,
scheduled to open this fall.
At more than 300,000 square
feet, this building
will serve as the new home for the
Tepper
School of Business,
as well as a major hub
for collaboration,
innovation,
creativity
and entrepreneurship at Carnegie
Mellon.
Tepper Quad will create
unprecedented
opportunities to break
new barriers
and to work toward new discoveries,
new technologies,
new businesses
and new forms of expression.
As our institution continues to
grow and build for an evolving
future,
the Tepper Quad is the physical
realization of a new
model for 21st century research
and education,
and it will transform the CMU
experience for generations
of students to come.
David has given so much
to Carnegie Mellon,
to our nation
and the world,
and we're delighted to welcome him
back
to campus to share his
wisdom
with the Class of 2018.
Please join me in extending a warm
welcome to David A.
Tepper. David.
Good morning,
Class of 2018.
I have a speech here.
Nice binder.
I think I might read it later,
but just a couple of observations
first that I
didn't think about before.
Back
over there, I was standing next to
Kevin.
He's right there,
and we were talking.
His voice was shaking.
My voice was shaking.
We were both nervous as
heck. I was going to say another
word,
but I'm told I'm not supposed to say
those words
today.
So, we're coming out
and we're there
and we're both kind of like shakey a
little bit,
and then Kevin starts straightening
up.
He starts getting this strength
about
him, and he says,
"I'm starting to feel it.
These are my people.
My people."
He pointed out some friends over
there.
We said hi to his family over there.
His mother, Lauren,
who told me a couple of stories
about Kevin that I'm not
going to say now.
Went up the aisle,
shaked a few hands there,
said hello to Anne Wall.
Hi, Anne Wall. Yea, good to see you
over there.
And, you know, Kevin just came up
here
and gave the most fantastic
speech.
And I'm thinking, crap.
I cannot be as good because I got
something I got
to read, and it's twice as long
and I can't just kind of adlib it.
And then I was thinking,
well you know what — you
guys, Kevin's family,
you guys out here, students please.
All you guys here,
you're my people,
too.
OK.
You're my people,
too.
You're Carnegie Mellon people,
Carnegie Mellon students,
Carnegie Mellon graduates,
my people.
So,
help me out today.
I need help.
So, because I've got to read this,
and I don't know how it's going to
go.
So we'll get to see.
Alright.
Let me start by thanking Farnam
for that kind introduction, for that
kind introduction.
I've got to get this kind of right
here.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
And for
his leadership of Carnegie Mellon.
As you know, Farnam, this
place means the world to me.
It really is a treasure.
There's no other university
that brings together business.
Where are you?
Thank you.
The arts.
The humanities.
The sciences.
And the social sciences.
The way CMU does.
You're right there, good to see you.
Thanks also to my fellow trustees,
to my fellow alumni who are all over
the place
here.
Engineering?
I apologize.
They told me not to leave the
podium,
but I don't — I'm sorry about
that. And engineering!
Can I get a hard hat up here?
This thing. Alright.
I've now lost my place, but we'll
try.
Thanks also to my fellow trustees,
my fellow alumni,
and most of all to you guys,
you students,
and to your parents.
A special thanks
to my family and friends who are
here today.
And of course to
my 86-year-old mom.
I think she's over there. Hi,
Mom, are you over there someplace?
Mom, where are you?
Mom?
Someplace over there.
I think my mom's a little happy
and proud today.
But my mom sometimes
can be a pain in the butt.
And I'm sure your parents can be,
too.
But there is nobody on Earth
I owe more to.
And there's nobody on Earth you owe
more
to than your parents.
In life,
in life,
you should recognize your parents.
So let's take a moment
and thank them.
And last but not least,
I want to congratulate
and thank my fellow honorary
doctors.
Ada.
Where are you, Ada? Ada is
a very funny lady.
I got to tell you this, whoever is
going to listen to her later.
A Nobel Prize winner, and she also
has a Nobel Prize.
It's a side thing.
Shafi Goldwasser,
a Turing Award winner,
and a guy I used to watch on TV when
I was younger.
Not that much younger.
An Emmy Award winner,
Ted Danson. You're catching
up to your wife, Ted.
His wife has a couple doctors more
than him, so he's catching up now.
It's amazing what you could find out
by talking to
people. Good thing
to listen.
Now, after the thank yous,
I think I'm supposed to start a
speech here.
And in preparing,
I was given advice from professional
speechwriters
and public relations people,
and,
of course,
my children.
They all told me not to be
too controversial
and try to be proper.
Let me apologize
to all of them in advance.
Sorry guys,
not going to happen.
I also prepared by listening to some
of the best
commencement speeches of all time.
Many were by actors,
some were by politicians,
all were delivered
with eloquence
and in a professional manner.
To all those
of attendance, to all those in
attendance,
if you were expecting to hear a
professional speech
today,
you may be at the wrong
commencement.
But what I can promise,
what I can promise you is as much
honesty
and personal life experiences
as I can muster.
I think people's lives are really a
combination
of different lives.
For students,
it's been a life you had before
college
with your parents,
and the life you had at college now,
and a life you are about to embark
on.
I'm sure some of you,
I'm sure some of you have overcome
incredible
adversity.
All of you have had,
and I can promise you'll all have
challenges,
disappointments
and triumphs.
I'm no different.
On the triumph side,
this has been a hell of a week.
A kid from the streets of Pittsburgh
who had to work his way through
college at Pitt
and grad school at CMU
just got an honorary doctor
and is giving a commencement speech
at this
university.
A kid,
a kid who couldn't afford to
go to an NFL game.
A kid, a
kid who —
sorry about that — a kid who
couldn't
afford to go to an NFL game
until well into his 20s
is on the verge of getting the NFL's
approval
to buy the Carolina Panthers.
Not too shabby,
but believe me,
it didn't start out that way.
I grew up,
I grew up in a working-class
neighborhood of Stanton
Heights in the city of Pittsburgh.
We played touch football in the
street
and tackle football in a nearby
cemetery.
We tried to not hit the gravestones.
The cellphone of the day
was mom calling up the street to say
dinner was ready.
My dad, like a lot of dads,
had to work 60-hour weeks just
to make ends meet.
But he taught me a couple of things,
a couple of important lessons.
First, always think about charity
and those less fortunate.
He gave even when my family didn't
have enough.
And another lesson: He used to ask
us,
"Who do you treat better,
the president
or the garbage man?"
Do you guys know the answer?
Garbage man? I'm talking just
generally
— not about any specific president
by the way.
Garbage man?
Garbage man,
garbage man may be the right answer
because somebody's
got to take your trash every day,
right? And if he doesn't take your
trash,
you're really in trouble.
But actually, the answer is
you treat them both the same.
All men
and women,
deserve to be treated equally
and with respect.
Despite these good things about my
dad,
he had a bad side, too.
He was physically abusive to me.
I'm sure it was a cycle
that he got from his father,
and his father got from his father.
In my young life,
there was nothing more terrifying.
There is no greater adversity.
But I prayed to God
that I would never be the same to my
children.
And I'm proud to say,
in what I view as the
greatest accomplishment of my life,
I
broke that cycle.
Thank you.
Now I'm shaking.
High school was at an
inner city school called Peabody.
It was about half white
and half African-American.
There really was a lot of tension at
the school,
between us at the school
back then,
and between the different high
schools.
Things were so bad between
Westinghouse
High School
and Peabody — I think it's now
called a
Barack Obama High — that
when we played each other in
football it was
in front of empty stands to keep
people from fighting.
It was rough.
There was actually no
grass on the field.
It was dirt,
rocks,
and they used to oil down the field
to keep the
dust from coming up.
True story.
One field goal post was against the
school.
The other field goal post was
against a fence.
If you ran out of the end zone,
you had real problems.
So I played a little football in
high school,
and I was also in school plays,
CFA.
But money being short,
I had a work.
My first job application
was at McDonald's.
I got turned down.
I did.
I think it was because I had an
oversized
Afro.
Wouldn't be a problem today.
I actually want to take it off,
it was so frickin' hot up here,
I gotta tell you.
But I did get a job as a short-order
cook
in a deli.
I also sold knives door-to-door.
And I was a union worker in a
bakery.
After high school, I went to the
University of Pittsburgh.
Where is it? Down there?
There,
where I ate at the "Dirty O," the
Original
Hot Dog. Anybody, Original Hot Dog
fans?
You like the French fries better,
or you like the hot dogs better?
French fries? Raise your hand.
Hot dogs?
Alright. French fries win the day.
Ate at the "Dirty O," had a
girlfriend
or two, and worked at the Fine Arts
Library
and got an honors degree in
economics.
After Pitt, I worked at a bank for a
little
and then came to Carnegie Mellon for
my
MBA.
Even though it was hard work,
I actually loved this place.
It was also the foundation for
everything
I've done professionally since then.
This place.
This place gave me the
tools I needed to be successful.
It really did.
I'm not kidding.
Well,
when I graduated I kind of liked
markets
and investments,
so I tried to get a job
with Goldman Sachs,
but they rejected me.
Didn't get a job there.
We'll come back to Goldman Sachs a
little later.
So after I got my MBA,
I made an unusual choice at the
time.
I went to work for Republic Steel.
That wasn't a great time for steel,
but I knew I would be exposed to a
lot,
and I really wanted to learn.
About three months after
I got to Republic Steel,
they gave a 7 percent
across-the-board
pay cut.
Pay cut.
All my business school buddies,
all my business school friends,
called me up and said,
"Great choice,
Tep!"
In two years, Republic Steel had to
merge
to avoid bankruptcy,
but it was a great choice.
And in those two years that they
were trying to save
the company, Republic did
more finance deals than it had in
its previous
100-year history.
And I learned from each one of them.
There's a lesson here.
In life,
in life,
get all the experience you can.
While you're young, go for the
experience versus
a paycheck.
That kind of experience got me a job
at a
mutual fund specializing in
distressed companies,
and eventually in the door
of Goldman Sachs,
where in a short time,
because of my previous job
experience
and cutting-edge things, cutting
edge things
I learned at CMU,
I advanced quickly
and became the head trader at
Goldman's junk desk.
That gave me more status than I knew
at that time,
but what I really wanted was to
become a partner.
I was up for partner for a few times
but never made it.
One of the reasons was I had to
refuse a powerful partner's request.
The story is this:
The partner had started a new fund
to invest in bankrupt companies,
and I was supposed to make the
trades for him.
He was also the partner who
controlled our restricted
lists.
That's the list of companies where
you might have some
conflicts
or some sensitive information.
He asked me to buy a company that he
had
just removed from the restricted
list
that day, that day.
It didn't seem right.
In fact,
I went to our legal department
and told them what was going on.
They said it would be okay after a
lot of
back and forth,
but it still didn't feel right to
me.
So, I refused again.
I didn't get fired,
but when I came up for partner,
I got shot down.
And I was incredibly upset.
But you know what,
you know what?
It turned out alright.
Because I didn't end up a partner
at Goldman Sachs,
I started my own company 25
years ago, in 1993,
called Appaloosa
and ended up doing something that
was a lot more
fun
and made my life better in so
many ways.
In life,
in life,
do what's right.
Really, do what's right,
and it won't hurt you.
Just keep your priorities straight.
You know I keep saying in life,
but really, as I said before,
there are many lives.
I've had an incredible life from
humble beginnings.
I've raised three great kids,
have a woman I love.
I've had a successful business
career
and incredible philanthropic
endeavors.
And now I am speaking to you
as a newly named doctorate,
and I am on the verge of being named
an NFL
owner.
You guys,
you guys, you students. Is it OK to
say guys,
students, girls? Girls, guys,
these guys,
girls, whatever. You
students. Sorry. You had a life
with your parents,
then a life at CMU,
and you're going to have a few more
lives.
Right now,
like I did, I think right now,
y'all have negative balance sheets.
But you have so much
upside.
You all have great opportunities
ahead.
Don't let anyone,
anyone,
tell you different.
You live in what was,
is,
and always will be,
the land of opportunity
and the greatest and most generous
country in the
world.
Remember,
remember this.
Last thing: When all
you become successful,
remember to give back,
give back.
God bless all of you.
God bless C-M-U.
And God bless America.
Thank you.